now I'd like to introduce today's
presenters Nilda swanee is an instructor
and co-director
for the Stanford advanced computer
security certificate in the past he has
served in a variety of research
development teaching and managerial
roles at Twitter defense Google and
Stanford University
Neal is also a co-author of foundations
of security what every programmer needs
to know and has published extensively in
these areas having been quoted by
publications such as the New York Times
USA Today and CSO magazine Neal earned
his PhD and MS degrees in computer
science at Stanford and he holds a BS in
computer science with honors from
Columbia now I'd like to turn the floor
over to Neal great thank you very much
for that introduction Joe in addition to
the companies that you've mentioned I've
also served in managerial roles in the
area security both at LifeLock and
Symantec and I'm supposed to be chatting
with all of you today about some of the
big name breaches that have taken place
over the past few years you know if we
look at what's going on in the field for
the past 15 years there have been more
than a billion customer records that
have been stolen there have been
thousands upon thousands of breaches
that have impacted many organizations
and so there's a lot to be learned from
from these breaches one of the reasons
that I think it's important to make sure
we cover these kinds of lessons and then
and that we can all learn from these
lessons is because you know there's a
this adage that you know those who don't
know history are doomed to repeat it and
I think even when you you know all the
lessons look at you know various world
leaders they are very very aware of
history and still it's it could be
challenging to keep oneself out of
trouble
so given what's taking place in the
industry there's a lot to learn there's
lots of organizations that have been
victimized by significant breaches and
the ones that we highlight here are
not like that we're talking about to to
shave any of them but rather I think as
a community of enterprises we need to
read all you know get better and be on a
path of continual improvement with
regard to security so that we can combat
some of the adversaries whether they be
organized couple criminal groups or
potentially even nation-states so let's
go ahead and start by covering a few of
the breaches that have just occurred in
the first five months of this year and
I'm going to cover not only two breaches
but one incident that may not be
considered a breach I'll talk a little
bit about why that is but if we just
look at the first five months of 2017
there have been over two hundred forty
three big breaches of her data from the
breach database of privacy rights
network and overall the CMO or modus
operandi for sure some of these speeches
has been similar to what they have been
I say over the past four to five years
this diagram here on the Left talks
about the attacker lifecycle and I'll
cover that in a bit more detail let me
chat a little bit about some of the more
recent breaches one of the organizations
that was impacted by a breach earlier
this year is a dun and Bradstreet
some of you may have heard of dun &
bradstreet they're an organization that
tracks information about businesses
mostly for the purpose of helping other
organizations assess the credit
creditworthiness of those of those
businesses they also happen to have
databases of you know large numbers of
individuals in corporate America from
CEOs to executive vice president's
senior vice presidents to managers
across organizations and one of the
issues that occurred earlier this year
in March is that it appears that their
database of individuals in corporate
America was was stolen now dun &
bradstreet as a company sells that
database to a number of other
organizations and
did some statements that dun bradstreet
submit they don't believe it was there
information security countermeasures
that were breached but they sell the
data to a whole bunch of other
organizations and they believe that it
is actually one of the other
organizations one of the customers that
were that were Greek and so one of the
things that we'll see in some of the
other big name breaches I talked about a
little bit later is that vetting your
your third-party suppliers has become
more and more important we'll talk about
that in relation to for instance the
target breach in a few minutes but
what's interesting about the dun and
bradstreet breach is that it may have
been the security one of the customers
that was breached and so typically you
know when you buy something from a
company you think about okay you need to
vet their information security practices
you typically don't think about it the
other way around where when somebody you
buy something from you you have to worry
about their information security
practices but this is an example where
if you're selling data about your
customers or other individuals to other
companies well maybe maybe one might
need to look the other way around
that was the done in broad straight
weeks let me chat a little bit next
about the River City media breach so
River City media is an email marketing
company and earlier this year they had a
list of about 1.3 billion customer Wells
not customer but 1.3 billion names and
email addresses that they would
typically market to and that data
effectively was bleached should
effectively inadvertently released out
onto the internet because they had they
were using a UNIX tool called our sink
to back up their database of email
addresses and that there was a
configuration problem with that
arsenic process where it was a set up so
that it inverted Lee I'll allow the
information to be viewable by anybody on
the Internet
so that was a second breach that
occurred this year the third issue that
I want to talk about incident that I
want to talk about
because this year is the one a crime
incidents so so wanna cry is the short
form of a name of a piece of malware
malicious software that would once it
infect somebody's machine it would in it
would basically encrypt files on the
hard drive or the local storage of the
machine that was infected it's a piece
of ransomware so once once that data got
encrypted using a key that holy known to
the attacker the attacker would then ask
the individual of the company that was
expected to pay a ransom I believe it
was about $300 is a few hundred dollars
if they want to have their files
decrypted so the one a cry incident had
affected over 200 thousand machines
across the internet and the reason that
I say that I was saying an incident as
opposed to a breach is that typically in
a breach there's an exfiltration of the
the data in an unencrypted way in this
case when want to cry or another piece
of ransomware infects the machine it
encrypts the data and keeps it local to
the machine that's infected and it
doesn't necessarily need to get
infiltrated and so that that may or may
not qualify as a bleach it certainly
qualifies as a compromise but you know
if you look at the various uh
you know state breach laws and I'll just
mention up front I'm not an attorney it
may or may not qualify him as a as a
breach but it's certainly an interesting
incident the reason that that one a
crime ransomware was able to propagate
in effect so many machines on the
internet was because it took advantage
of a vulnerability in a distributed file
protocol the SMB protocol on Windows and
what was interesting about this is that
the vulnerability that was used there
was a patch made available in mid-march
and so if one simply patched before it
hit in May then one the machines should
not be
second but it just emphasizes how
important regular patching is so so
those are three breaches slash incidents
that occurred just just this year now
B's you know if you look at some of
these numbers if you look at the River
City media breach it has a very
significant number of 1.3 4 billion
it was mostly names and email addresses
there have been larger breaches that
have been taking place that have taken
place over the years and more
significant breaches in the way the
information that was stolen so let me go
ahead and chat a little bit about some
of those breaches as well before I go on
to talking about specific breaches and
we'll start with the operation just a
second I just want to double click into
the diagram that I had on the previous
slide a little bit more this diagram
shows typically the typical attacker
lifecycle so you know very often we can
end up focusing on our work and what's
convenient and what we need to do to get
our jobs done
but attackers whether they're cyber
criminals whether they're nation-state
attackers they have a different view of
the world and there's been a number of
these types of diagrams that have been
produced over the past few years this
particular one is um is available on
Wikipedia but it shows that there is a
cycle that attackers follow where they
first define what their target is and
then they effectively take a
mission-based approach to going about
achieving their goals this is very
different than the way that attackers
used to operate 10 or 15 years ago where
very often somebody would write a worm
or a virus and deploy it out with the
Internet and the goal was to just make a
name for themselves that's typically not
the case anymore the the attackers you
know what even when they make an initial
compromise they don't close it to the
world even if they can to face your
homepage they don't do that right away
they will look at the initial
compromised as a first step in their
attack and they'll figure out what else
they can do and so once they define
their target they will figure out hey
are there other cyber criminal
that they want to work together with
they may build a required tools to
target particular organizations they may
develop custom malware they may they may
understand a little bit about how the
organization works and how to target
their particular countermeasures they
will research their targets whether
their targets be executives of the
company whether there are targets our
system administrators of the company
they'll spend time on social networks to
understand who are the people they
should target one of their roles if
there is an important executive and
maybe they think the executive might not
fall for the attack who is their
administrative assistant how can they
they try to dupe the event rated
assistant into clicking on the wrong
thing for instance once they develop
their tools they'll build traps for
detection don't deploy they'll make some
initial intrusion they'll inspect some
machining they'll get credentials to
some particular account and then they
will you know continue their attack once
they establish a footprint of a
compromised machine say they will
initiate a found connections that they
can persistently control that machine on
an ongoing basis and use it as a as a
beachhead to do additional
reconnaissance and scan to see well what
the machines can be in fact what other
information can they get access to and
they'll pretty much continue this
process over months or years until they
accomplish the mission whether their
mission is gentle intellectual property
still identities
still trade secrets and and and so on
and so forth one of the things that this
that this diagram shows kind of in the
center is that not all attackers are
equal there are some very determined
attackers that will put in that kind of
effort and they're typically refer to as
advanced persistent threats and so
you'll see as denoted by the purple that
attackers that are in that category will
carry out all of the steps in this
particular a lot attacks lifecycle
diagram at the same time there might be
say lower tier cyber criminal groups I
wouldn't call them you know lower tier
in their methods of attack but I'd call
the lower care
and say the amount of resources that
they have is compared to a nation-state
and they may in order to accomplish
interval in their mission if they simply
want to monetize a bunch of machines
that they infect and have them
participate in the botnet and rent out
those compromised machines to others
they may not need to pursue all of the
steps in this particular diagram so if
you look at the orange for instance
you'll see that they may build a require
tool they may test for detection don't
deploy but they they may not spend as
much time researching via social media
all of these you know employees or
individuals and organization but they
want to target so this is the typical
attack attacker lifecycle and as I
talked up some of the large breaches
you'll see me describe some of the
different parts of this in talking about
the attacks so with that let's let's
talk about the first breach or set of
breaches and we were chat about the
breach that occurred against Yahoo that
was discovered in 2016 and so there's an
asterisk up to the top right of 2016
because that's when the attack was
discovered the breaches actually took
place in 2013 and 2014 there were
actually two distinct regions they
disclosed one breach of over 500 million
user records and then another follow-on
breach of a billion plus user records
and you know if and so just for
convenience I will talk about those
breaches you know together as well and
even they were even though they were two
distinct breaches if I if we look at
what information was was stolen in those
user records that included you know not
just names and email addresses but it
included telephone numbers it included
the security questions and answers that
one typically sets up when you set up a
web-based account such that even if
somebody didn't have your password they
could try to use the answers to those
questions to gain access to your account
the stolen information included dates of
birth as well as hashed passwords that
said due to the scope of the bleach that
occurred
what the attackers label do is get
access to actually all billion plus
yahoo accounts and they were able to
login to any of those accounts at will
without a password how did they do that
I'll talk about that in just a second so
this breach was the largest breach that
occurred in the history of the internet
Yahoo was in the midst of getting
acquired by Verizon Communications at
the time that the breach was discovered
and it was a breach that was material
enough they were getting acquired I
think for four billion plus dollars
probably close to five billion dollars
and upon disclosure of the breach given
that it was material verizon dropped the
price of the acquisition by three
hundred and fifty million dollars which
is pretty inexpensive in and of itself
not including all the costs at Yahoo
probably had to incur to do forensics
and investigations and pay an attorney
fees and whatnot so it's a very
significant breach probably most
significant trade shows of all times of
sir and resulted in you know issues to
tiata valuation so those are some of the
impacts but there are number of other
attacks as well you know given that
attackers and by the way that the tactic
seductiveness attack were made up of two
Russian spies and two cyber criminals
and you know one of the one of the kind
of interesting documents that I read
course and preparation webinar was the
indictment of those individuals there's
a reference to it at the end of the top
but the attack was significant not only
for these you know financial reasons but
the attackers given that they could you
know login to pretty much anybody yahoo
account they started targeting diplomats
they started targeting particular
executives they just went after about
6500 very target
folks given of course that the list of
all of these records were stolen one
could use them to do mass phishing
attacks but there's many other things
that could have taken place the the
attackers use the combination of spear
phishing and Malware to getting in fact
their attack was significant enough that
they were able to infect Yahoo search
engines so they could return whatever
links that they wanted that will and so
in addition to the attacks that they
conducted they set up a bunch of
affiliate deals and started serving
links on Yahoo search engine and
monetizing the the traffic from people
clicking on those links so so that
that's the pretty significant impact how
did that how did that occur so you know
the FBI pretty much traced the beginning
of this attack to a phishing attack in
particular to a spear phishing attack so
for those of you that are familiar with
phishing you know that even going back
10 years that it would be many attackers
that would send out emails that claimed
the visa from some bank and they would
hope that when they sent you that email
that you have an account to that bank
and that you'll click on the link and
you'll go to the imposter web page that
they set up and enter your username
password for your bank and you know the
attackers site would just return some
error saying oh you know you're logging
didn't work please try again later but
what the attacker would do with those
stolen credentials then is then go login
to your bank and try to fence for money
out of it and those were kind of the
initial state of phishing attacks but
over time attackers develop more
sophistication so that they started
doing spear phishing attacks where the
attacks were pay not necessarily
targeted at consumers broadly but they
were targeted at individuals and
corporations and the goal was to get
particular individuals to give up their
credentials for certain corporate
accounts and for corporate systems so
why bother trying to look for
vulnerabilities and try to break into a
whole bunch of machines if you can just
even
employee and get them to give you their
credentials and so so the attack against
Yahoo in fact started with spearfishing
against not an executive and you know
not read of employees but a particular
employee and set of employees that were
semi privileged that happen to have
access to certainly systems at Yahoo
some of the key systems that mattered
were Yahoo's user database and Yahoo's
tool that they used for account
management there was also another tool
that was used to to generate cookies and
so let me let me just finish talking a
little bit about spear phishing and
Malware and then I'll chat a little bit
about how the how the cookie theft
occurred and how that allowed attackers
to access all Yahoo email accounts so
you know spear phishing attacks they
very often are seeking to steal set of
user credentials and employee
credentials but in addition given that
drug I downloads can occur where to
infect the machine these days you don't
need to even do the user into clicking
yes or downloading something and
double-clicking on it to run you can you
can simply if you can send over email
where you can dupe somebody into just
clicking on a link then upon the victim
clicking on the link they will get
infected just by opening the webpage and
the way that happens is by drive-by
download where the infected webpage will
fingerprint what browser is the victim
running what are all the different
third-party plug-ins that the victim is
running and within a couple hundred
milliseconds the attackers exploit
toolkit on the infected web page figures
out what vulnerable versions of software
running and simply does a lookup in an
online database to figure out what's the
piece of malicious code that they need
to spend down to exploit that
vulnerability of infect the machine and
take it over and so so spear phishing
attacks often also contain these links
to drive-by down
so since the attacks against Yahoo
started with spear phishing and Malware
that was used to infect machines and the
attack was able to get access to these
to these young systems I mentioned that
one of the systems was a tool that
allows the attacker to effectively mint
cookies so for those of you that that
you know know how most websites work
right if there's a website which
requires a login you present the user
with a username and password field and
have them type in the username and
password and then once their username
and password checks out you give them
back a cookie a server will give that a
cookie to the users browser and after
that interaction it's that cookie that
keeps going back and forth between the
website and the users browser and that
cookie actually authenticates the user
so that the user doesn't have to enter
their username and password I leverage
to a webpage and so well if you're an
attacker and you can figure out how a
website creates its cookies then you
actually don't need anybody's passwords
to log it you can just Forge cookies and
walk into the website and go from there
and that's exactly what happened in the
in the Yahoo attack and that's how the
attackers were able to access all yahoo
email accounts at will without passwords
that's the yahoo breach and that was
discovered in 2016 I'm going to talk
about a couple other breeches that were
discovered in 2015 and 2014 and then I'm
going to chat a little bit about some
defenses against now learn to fishing
but one thing that you'll see is that in
a lot of these big name breaches
phishing and Malware have been the tools
of choice that attackers have been using
so let me talk about the next breach the
Office of Personnel Management breach
from 2015 the Office of Personnel
Management is a government agency that
has or had or so has all the background
track records so anytime that you apply
to be a government employee and or have
to go through a security clearance
there's a form called sf-86 tender form
86 and it not only contains as you might
imagine all the previous addresses that
you used to live
and all places that used to work and
whatnot but it has that information for
all of your family members and what
God's stolen during the personnel
management breach in 2015 was all of
those all of those records
it also included by the way 5.6 million
fingerprint records and so what was the
impact of that attack you know if you if
you read the health oversight committees
majority staff report on this on this
breach you know a direct quote from
there in terms of what the impact was
that it will harm counterintelligence
efforts for at least a generation to
come the value of the stolen background
information for a foreign nation cannot
be overstated nor will it ever be
formally known that's um you know quite
significant the damages are been done
it's a significant blow to to country's
intelligence efforts and
counterintelligence effort how did it
happen
you know overall the information
security program at the Office of
Personnel Management was was
under-resourced and the amount of
priority that has given to security was
was was not enough the u.s. computer
emergency response team had actually
identified that there was an
exfiltration from the Office of
Personnel Management it was kind of a
part of reach one they notify the office
personnel management and basically a set
of teams were set up to monitor the
first breach and then there was a second
breach but basically it wasn't you know
even after that first breach occurred is
discovered that there was malware on a
number of key machines including I
believe a jump box a jump box is
typically a machine that's in between
ones you know development contested
staging networks and ones production
network and that machine that was
affected was seems to be running a
process a dynamically linked library
that had a particular name that was
actually
you know indicative of McAfee security
software unfortunately though the OPM
was about a McAfee customer and so that
was simply a piece of malware and a name
being used to masquerade the attackers
toolkit that were using a rootkit called
high kick
there isn't true variants and B and that
malware was used to purportedly monitor
accounts and you know steal more
information so the program there what
was unresearched and there was a
sequence of breaches one of the things
that could have been done to present
prevent this breach was to use
multi-factor authentication to use
two-factor authentication so that you
know even if say some machines got
infected and even if some account
credentials got solar from there you
know if you require more than just a
username and password to access to the
critical systems then you know and let
us say some two-factor code that gets
sent to a person's mobile phone or
whatnot then the attacker would have had
to affect in fact not only a bunch of
machines but also people's phones so so
that could have that could have
potentially helped one of the challenges
that the office personal management had
is that they had a lot of legacy systems
and keeping legacy systems patched so
that they can't be infected by malware
can can often be a challenge so a little
bit about the office of personnel
management breach going back a a year or
actually also in 2015
let me also chat about the anthem breach
anthem provides health care services to
a significant fraction of the country
and in 2015 they had a breach where 80
million customer records were stolen
those records included people's names
their date of birth their social
security numbers their health care IDs
and there has been a
more than a hundred lawsuits that
occurred in this particular case there
was a database users credentials that
were stolen and the way the breach got
noticed is that one of the
administrators had noticed that there
was a database query running that they
didn't issue and so the issue I think
occurred the initial compromise might
have happened in you say April but in
December of January in a month later
this query was noticed to be running and
was taking up a lot of resources and so
once it was investigated that that the
credentials were stolen
it set off the whole incident response
process I have the next slide here on
how they have the rich happened in in
more detail and you know will return to
a house has been prevented and just said
basically there are a couple steps the
attacker sent in a phishing email with a
link to well point calm well point
spelled with two ones and so two else
the victims clicked on it the victim
machines got infected
just from the click malware was
installed on the victim system and then
that system God got monitored right once
once the attacker owns the system they
can modern all traffic that goes through
it
and they were able to monitor for
account credentials so what happens from
there is that the attacker stole the
credentials and use those credentials to
start closing queries against anthems
databases and then issued a query for
this eighty million data set and that's
how that's the point at which the
attacker got discovered so so that
deftly has a breach I'll pop it about
just one or two more glitches I'll talk
about the JPMorgan Chase bridge that
happened in 2014 in this particular each
walk on stolen was 70 million customer
names and email addresses one of the
things that
interesting about this bridge you could
imagine that JPMorgan Chase is a bank
invests a lot in security and you know
there is you know this kind of
information stolen it can be used for
math potential phishing attacks
of course because the attacker stole the
information from this data set at cheapo
gonna chase they they know that all the
customers have taken Lauren change
accounts so so there's that that master
there is a potential for mass phishing
attacks but given that it impacted Bank
you know one of the silver windings here
in this particular breach is that you
know one could imagine that that was
worse the attackers could have just
directly stolen money out of people's
accounts or deleted information or just
took direct financial control which
which didn't happen so it's unfortunate
attack curve but it could have equipment
a lot worse how did this particular
attack occur again there was a phishing
email that was sent to steal some
employee credentials and then those
employee credentials were leveraged by
the attacker now JP Morgan Chase did
have two factor authentication deployed
on many many many of their servers
unfortunately there was one third-party
server there was a nonprofit that did
some work for the furtherance of the
bank I believe that they helped organize
you know fundraisers marathon something
like that but basically there was one
server on which two-factor
authentication was not deployed and so
the attacker was able to use the sole
user and password to get to this data
so what could have prevented it well
anti-phishing training you know if if if
an employee s employees can be better
trained to recognize phishing attacks
and or more quickly report them to for
much the better and then of course you
got to get to fact on all servers if you
miss even one tax can take advantage of
that
that's JPMorgan Chase breach and finally
I'll talk about the target breach in the
target breach in 2013 what got stolen
was 40 million credit card numbers
that's the bad news the good news is is
that you can reset people's credit card
numbers and customers are typically not
accountable or liable but the way that
the way that this occurred was actually
initially via a third party supplier
that target used they had affirmed by
the name of Fawzia mechanical services
that was responsible for running the air
conditioning and heating at all of the
retail branches and the attacker first
broke into faulty mechanical services
and took advantage of the fact that
their networks were connected together
and they started sending out a whole
bunch of malware Laden phishing emails
and over a series of months basically
got to a point where they were able to
with malware infect the point-of-sale
stations that were in the retail stores
and they were able to start exfiltrating
data out of those point-of-sale stations
as customers would scan their parts so
you know in this particular case on
network segmentation could have helped
this their air-conditioning's network
access was segmented off from the rest
of the companies access that that could
have helped the turkey attackers further
and you know target did have some
anti-malware technology deployed they
had a set of folks out sourced abroad
that were looking through all the alerts
and there were significant number alerts
that indicated there was a breach going
on there now other factions taking place
some of those notifications were getting
escalated up to their headquarters but
there were so many alerts that they they
they couldn't and weren't able to
respond to them and you know there might
have been enough false positive alert
fake alarms effectively that it was hard
it may have been hard to discern when
what were the real alerts or was a real
Miller set to be happening so in any
case that surveys a whole bunch of the
big name breaches that have taken place
over the past four years I've been a you
know talk about some of the key key
attack vectors and defenses
in all these packs and all these big
game attacks phishing and Malware has
been have been used as tools of choice
by the attackers I'm going to talk talk
about a bunch of Defense's when it comes
to fishing or make sure that you know
one of the things that you can do is
train your employees give them awareness
training for how to recognize phishing
attacks how do you recognize malicious
drumming and how do you recognize
malicious urls and in many organizations
one good practice is to regularly try to
fish your own employees by the security
team sends out fake phishing emails and
sees what percentage of the employees
fall for the fault for the test attack
and then continue you know
quarter-over-quarter year-over-year with
helping the employees they just get
better and better at recognizing such
tax one of the things that could happen
in those things is that when you train
employees to recognize attacks and then
have them start sending in attacks what
can you look at asset from time to time
this will send in an email saying hahaha
you tried to get me with your with your
fake attack but I caught you and
sometimes the email response that comes
back from security is actually that was
enough that was a real attack so thank
you for being a human sensor to
complement all of our technology to help
us gather data on when we're getting
attacked part of the purpose of training
that is important is to recognize and to
train employees to report phishing
attacks because once the cheek attacks
to occur it's not necessarily game over
if some if some user did get duped into
providing their username and password
but then reports it in well security
team can help reset those credentials so
that the criminal cut stolen aren't
effective or let's say that somebody is
systems on infected with malware well
you can take steps to contain that
malware and reimage your machine and and
cut off the attack but there's got to be
that training so the fast reporting
credentials reset is important
other technologies that can be important
in making email more secure is
leveraging technologies like SPF and
DKIM Demark that in an SPF you can
declare well what are they you know you
can imagine that attackers if you're
working for a company called fubar comm
attackers might want to scoop emails
coming from that domain so that it
appears like it's coming from the
organization and by using technologies
like SPF and DKIM Demark and by signing
all emails that go out from the
organization and instructing the
internet to drop such emails you can
make it much much harder for attackers
to try to spoof your own to me and kind
of force them to use other domains and
so then if users have the appropriate
training to look out for STEMI looking
domains attending ticket help and then
another important defense is to leverage
multi-factor authentication so that if
this attacker steal a particular user
and password credential that credential
internet itself cannot be used to access
a critical system and it requires
another key factor code to come via
another out-of-band channel in order to
provide access to a system that's
fishing in some defenses and then
there's members malware having important
anti-malware defenses is very important
and it's actually important to go beyond
there's traditional antivirus which want
use signature-based techniques to
recognize malware that's been already
deployed but you want to spend against
malware that hasn't been recognized yet
so various endpoint production products
on the market well in addition to using
signatures they'll use heuristics
they'll use machine learning that will
leverage cloud intelligence from samples
that have come in from customers to to
achieve a network effect and detection
those are all those are all good
defenses in addition when there is any
piece of executable code that looks like
it might be suspicious one can leverage
local service dissemble space detection
where that malware gets spun up into a
virtual machine and you test well what
is that what does that binary do
so even if there's no signature for it
and maybe if it sets off some heuristics
you see what what does it actually do
when it gets and trucks running on a
machine
there's also Troodon section
technologies that could be used systems
like sort and grow that are well-known
intrusion detection systems which which
few take advantage of signatures but
basically gives you detection not just
on the hosts themselves but as a network
layer of the firewall layer and other
parts of the network and then one other
thing that you can do is on machines
that could potentially get infected
limit the privileges that users are
allowed to have on their machines you
can imagine that that if you can limit
privileges and say not let users install
software on their machines then if even
if an attacker compromises that machine
they they won't be able to install
malicious software so living the
privileges can be important you know I
talked about the attack against Yahoo so
it is important if you bring web
applications to make sure that the
cookie is that your site generates are
strong and very often what goes into
cookies and you know they get generated
based off of some secret key or some
combination of a secret key plus a
per-user nonce and so it's important to
protect those keys have strong key
management and you know they do all
these topics our topics have you covered
a number of our of our courses here at
Stanford but let me let me chat a little
bit about some defenses more generally
you know I've talked a lot about - the
big name breaches here and phishing and
Malware has been a set of tools that
attackers of use to accomplish these
negative reaches but you know most
breaches in fact occurred you too
Anette realistics made by employees or
some set of humans and so it's important
to you know dot just have anti-male
learn anti-phishing defenses but to have
a set of Defense's that what employees
at an organization to have a holistic
defense and to have countermeasures that
and not only against the the most
intricate sub criminals these kind of
big-name types of text but also defend
against all the inadvertent things that
can that can go wrong and so employing
an approach where you have some
countermeasures that prevent is a good
thing for instance data minimization if
you don't need the data don't store it
if you don't store it you can't be
stolen and there's a whole bunch of
other prevention approaches that list
here but you've got a couple that
together with good detection
good containment and good recovery
countermeasures how one reacts when
there's issues can be just as important
as preventing issues in another themself
is one of the things about it things
have been learned over the years if
you're an organization and you're
working to improve your security and
monitor your security how can you do
that how can you do that quantitatively
so there's a there's a number of
services these days that allow you to
measure your security posture and so the
security scorecard is a company that's
funded by Google Ventures they provide
one such service where they measure ten
different areas of your security and for
instance they measure your endpoint
security they help identify if you do
have infected machines on your network
that might be participating in botnets
networks of compromised machines and
they do that by monitoring the upon
networks and what IP they are connecting
in them and are any of those IP
addresses yours but employment service
like this can help you get a sense for
your overall security posture and and
can be very good in helping help you
figure out where you need to make
improvement one of the what are the
challenges of course is that you know
such as such things may not be fully
comprehensive for instance you know are
you using two-factor authentication are
you doing phishing tests and
anti-phishing trainings that that may or
may not be directly captured by it by
some of these measurements in a number
of these areas you know typical security
scorecard report though will have a lot
of data and it'll have some overview
that you know gives you
grades in these different areas and
helps you monitor the data over time
this is a sample report for a fictional
organization called ever grocery but can
be helpful you know for instance looking
at packing cadence it if you have any
machines that you know are not being
patched regularly externally then it
could be susceptible to incidents like
want to cry so this kind of data can be
helpful another such tool that could be
used is a tool called quad metrics that
was acquired actually by FICO the the
same organization that monitors credit
scores and the reason I mentioned quad
metrics is because they are also looking
at what are many of these different
features and aspects that one can
observe to assess external security
posture and I mention them because they
have some published research back in
2015 a number of the early employees and
founders I believe of the company
published a paper at the use extroyer
fluid security symposium and in their
paper they described how they looked at
two hundred fifty eight features that
one can just observe and see if there's
any disbandment happening with an
organization security are there SSL
certificates enter misconfigured are
some of the IP is an organization's owns
involved in doing spam and phishing
attacks and they built a random forest
predictive classifier so that they could
predict which organizations are most
likely to get breached and without
getting into the details we cover this
in our enroll detail in our cyber
security for executives course they they
kind of other models and then looked at
well back in 2014
could they predict which organizations
like Ivy has gotten breached and based
on the way the classifier was trained to
came up with pretty high scores for some
of the organizations that were breached
now of course the real question is if we
will use this model today who they
predict is going to get breached next
year and year after that but it's really
it's really good to see the field
getting more quantitative and bringing
in more data to help assess security
posture
Health Organization's improve their
security so with that I'll just provide
a couple pointers where you can learn
more I mentioned we just done we just
rolled out I mentioned the cybersecurity
and effective strategy courses of course
that we just rolled out that helps you
as a as a as AI manager or as an
executive understand how do you measure
security how do you report to the board
how your pork counter management we have
a course of emergent suctioned defenses
we also have a course on software
security foundation so if you are just
getting into the field and one of our
more that's a great course of pink
there's a bunch of other links here to
some resources on the various breach
that I talked about for instance a link
to the indictment of the Russian spies
of cyber criminals in the case of the
OPM breach there's a link here to this
House Oversight majority staff report
there's a link to a presentation by some
folks from anthem themselves about how
that attack occurred and with that I
hope I hope you've enjoyed you know
learning how these thinking breaches
have occurred and hope that you've
enjoyed learning a little bit about some
of the countermeasures that that could
happen how the breach has occurred so
that hopefully we can all learn from
these lessons and prevent some of these
kinds of breaches from occurring in the
future thank you all right so now we'll
take a few minutes to answer some of
your questions looks like the first one
we have is with breach of being a part
of the mainstream media in the past few
years particularly politics security has
now become a much higher priority for my
company we have recently been approved
for a significant budget increase next
year and are discussed discussing
proposed strategies what areas do you
think will provide the best investment
so that is a question that will depend
upon your organization and what you know
who's targeting you what's your attack
surface and so to figure out what might
be some of the best areas for investment
what I just
is a step one to do a risk assessment
and have interviews with your employees
have you know bringing a lot of
quantitative and qualitative data and
assess what the risks are and then
figure out what are the countermeasures
whether it be people process technology
that what should put in place to address
those risks the first question let me um
let me take a stab at the next question
next question here is uh you know can we
define breach
I've heard this use this word use
different places resulting into the
meaning for example is a breach any data
is compromised or when it only refers to
certain set of standards and so the
question of what is the definition of
breach is an interesting one I would
actually encourage you to consult an
attorney there are data breach laws and
you know 45:47 plus of the states that
have them and they all define breach a
little bit differently the the
definition in you know California was
the first state that had such a data
breach club back in 2003 but the lowest
generally are of the form that you know
if there is unencrypted data that stolen
that contains say somebody's name of
some set of identifiers whatever then it
counts as our account of the breach and
each state's definition is a little bit
different than theirs that legal
definition of a breach you know
sometimes I've I've seen technical folks
throw around the word breach so for
instance like you know let's say that
malware infection system well if there's
no you know customer or personally
identifiable information that may not be
considered a breach so so that you know
so the answer is consult an attorney an
attorney will help you understand this
little definition of bleach and you know
go from there we have time for maybe one
more one more question and what
see I can only choose I guess what let's
see ah there's a question here I have a
question about the attacker website how
long couldn't have her maintain
connectivity with a victim in terms of
duration and after that is that some you
know an attacker could in theory
maintain connectivity indefinitely right
until the connectivity is cut off by for
some reason right so the the you know
how long an attacker wants to maintain
connectivity
how fast can an organization identify it
and cut it off those are all those are
all variables but there is nothing
inherent about the attacker lifecycle
that you know would limit how long the
attacker can maintain connectivity and
so you know with attacks having become
more mission based you know the the you
know attackers have been maintaining
connectivity you know much longer than
they have in the past it can range on
the order of months or years well great
thank you so much nail looks like that's
all the time we have left for this
webinar thank you all for joining us and
we hope you have a great rest of your
day